stable and book TV takes you there now
for five and a half hours of live
coverage up first Christopher Hitchens
the Vanity Fair contributing editor will
discuss his latest work a biography of
Thomas Jefferson you're watching live
coverage of the Annapolis Book Festival
here on book TV on c-span 2 distinct
honor and pleasure to be introducing
Christopher Hitchens this morning for
not only is he a fellow expatriate he
was also born in Portsmouth England as
was I and just now I figured out that we
actually we were born in the same
building educated at Oxford and anointed
by the British newspaper The Guardian as
one of the top 100 intellects mr.
Hitchens has written prolific Lee both
in books and for numerous magazines led
by the nation and Vanity Fair on
subjects as wide-ranging as Mother
Teresa
Ronald Reagan and Michael more recently
he published his latest book on Thomas
Jefferson once a darling of the left
he now issues his socialist past
although he still seems to hold some
affection for Marxism however he's
forsaken his erstwhile liberal friends
describing him as too righteous boring
and herbivorous his views then could not
be pigeonholed perhaps that word
contrarian best describes him ladies and
gentlemen please welcome Christopher
Hitchens
well first of all thank you very much
ladies and gentlemen coming and thank
you Paul for that very handsome
introduction nice to meet someone from
whom I could have been separated at
birth you I'm told ladies adjustment we
only have 3/4 of an hour together and so
it's an hour that's good all right well
I was going to say that I take it that
people like yourselves come to events
like this in order to speak as well as
to be spoken to so I'll try and be as
sparing with my share of the time as I
can be but bear in mind that mr.
Jefferson was in power almost
continuously one way or another for a
quarter of a century it's quite a
difficult life to compress into one book
and certainly into one talk I thought
I'd speak about in mind the four
headings four chief headings
enlightenment warn revolution
nation-building and slavery Jefferson
was slightly prone to self-pity he would
often say the burdens of office were too
great the appreciation of his efforts
was insufficient the business of
politics was too foul he constantly say
I'm not sure I'll be back on my farm in
Monticello he would now have said I mean
ought to spend more time with my family
and we would be able to add now from
what we know more time with his two
families but as it happens he could
easily have elected to do something
other than politics and have been
perhaps not as well known but equally
successful in the chosen field he could
have been an excellent lawyer he was a
very good lawyer
it took some quite early cases also
about emancipation he could have been an
extremely good librarian his private
library became the core of what is now
the Library of Congress in Washington he
designed a plow which dug a deep Ofuro
in the soil he could have been it was a
very good farmer he wouldn't have been a
very good wine grower he never got
Virginia wines up to snuff in fact they
still rather lag though I think they're
better than the Connecticut Chardonnay
he when he had settled a minor point in
a question about the rights of whaling
whalers Marin the moby-dick cents
between his country our country and
others he decides he'd have to write a
special treatise on it to study the
whole matter properly before he gave his
report it was a genuine polymath and the
city of Philadelphia in that time while
it might not have been the equivalent of
say the fifth century Athens was
becoming had become a magnet city for
that kind of talent scientific medical
philosophical and so forth obviously the
best known to us of this Pantheon is
Benjamin Franklin who has a reasonable
claim to have discovered at least the
workings of electricity in its
connection to lightning but for example
when Joseph Priestley who we can I think
rightly call the discoverer of oxygen
even though he believed in the
phlogiston theory for most of his life
was a brilliant scientist and after his
laboratory in Birmingham in England had
been smashed broken up by a mob shouting
for the church and the king these are
the supporters of Edmund Burke not all
of them were as polite or as polished as
mr. Burke was mr. Priestley decided to
take his remaining instruments and his
knowledge and cross the Atlantic and
bring them to Philadelphia where he knew
he'd be welcome there one could have met
people like dr. Benjamin Rush a very
distinguished physician also one of the
founders of the American anti-slavery
society Thomas Paine came across there
with a letter indeed of introduction
from Benjamin Franklin not just in order
to exert his fantastic skills as a
polemicist and public speaker but also
in the hope of designing which what had
never been tried before an iron bridge a
bridge that would span water and connect
distant places and survive the winter
wouldn't crack and splinter as wood
would do bridge building couldn't be a
better definition of an Enlightenment
project bridges a dialectical by
definition they don't go only one way
an ideal occupation for mr. Paine
Jefferson was absolutely in his element
in this world and I think there are two
achievements that we can that we can
tribute to this enlightenment atmosphere
to the sort of authors and writers who
they discussed in France in Italy Cesare
Beccaria for example whose book on
crimes and punishments have begun to
revolutionize thinking in Europe what up
until then executions and torture the
most barbaric kind have been very
commonplace when Jefferson became
governor of the state of Virginia he
produced an almost model Statute on
crime and punishment didn't actually
succeed in abortion with death penalty
I'm sorry to say but in but in
attempting a less retributive and more
rehabilitating more humane and more
scientific penal system that would be
one what I would call enlightenment
achievement and one that set a precedent
across the United States but the most
important one I believe but and probably
the major subject of conversation in
Philadelphia at that time was this or is
this once people had began to realize
that the world was not flat that the son
did not revolve around it that diseases
were not caused by Devils or by sin and
various other quite striking disclosures
of the kind they began also to think as
it were inevitably that well there might
be another explanation than creation for
the way the world was and though there
might be a designer
deism was very common among this group
people who believed in effect that the
order of nature showed the must have
been a god or at least a starter but it
didn't look as if this personal force
took any direct interest in human
affairs did not intervene did not answer
or listen to prayers was unstacked or
anything of backwardness that that it
was probably necessary to have a
separation in society and in government
between the church in the state no other
government before or since has ever
deliberated on this point and resolved
it in this way extremely revolutionary
idea at the time probably the fact that
the British crown had had its own
private church the Anglican Church
as call the Church of England or the
Episcopal Church which obviously was
going to be disestablished in America
the crown wasn't gonna have its own
church anymore may have made it easier
but it was proposed I'm talking again
now about the deliberations in the
Virginia assembly by Patrick Henry and
others will let us instead have the
government's support not one church but
all churches
everyone should be tithe for the support
of all churches there was to that
proposition in the context only one
reply which was that the government
should support no church and together
mr. Jefferson and his close lifelong
friend mr. Madison evolved the Virginia
statute on religious freedom how many
people have here have been to
Charlottesville to Monticello to see the
house no that's excellent well then you
know that on the but just for those who
are watching us and wishing they were as
knowledgeable as we were you will those
of you at home ladies and gentlemen may
not know that when mr. Jefferson
designed his own memorial which takes no
religious form by the way there's no
cross or anything like that or he didn't
have an attending priest of his deathbed
either which was long foreseen he only
mentions a very small number of
achievements he thought he only should
be remembered as founder of the
University of Virginia author of the
Declaration of Independence and author
of the Virginia statute on religious
freedom I didn't think it worth
mentioning that he'd been president
twice and Vice President and Secretary
of State and ambassador to France or
minister to France
so we can we can well see the salience
and he put on this and though because he
was in France he wasn't present at the
deliberations in Philadelphia that
resulted in the Constitutional
Convention
I think it's obvious when you look at it
that the Virginia statute on religious
freedom is the embryo of the first
amendment to the Constitution which is
my opinion the amendment that in acts if
you like all the others which makes a
clear separation between church and
state guarantees religious freedom by
their he means it which it can be
guaranteed just to say a secular state
and also guarantees the right of free
expression and free assembly the the the
extraordinary luck of having somebody
who could part of that intellectual
ferment of Philadelphia take it into
politics and then
to the law and then into a drafting
committee and finally into our
Constitution is something that I think
would be well certainly has been made a
book in itself so that's not all I want
to say about enlightenment but I've come
back to it by another route but the
second area where he was preeminent was
that of war and revolution in the first
place he drafts the manifesto of the
revolution most of it at any age
fails to get a clause condemning slavery
and being adopted fails to get it
sorry fails to get it adoption probably
because of the pressure of the Carolinas
and Georgia delegations but also because
of the number of slave traders not
holders also in New York but with that
terrible initial defeat conceded he he
announces if you like the first
democratic revolution until that time
the word democratical or democratic was
generally used as an insult as the
Greeks might have said autocratic or ma
Biche or mob rule to be accused of being
a Democrat was to be accused of favoring
essentially mob rule John Adams would I
think have continued using it in that
way for most of his life the word
democracy evolves as a non pejorative as
a positive word really out of the work
of Thomas Jefferson and might and in my
opinion the unacknowledged draft of the
Declaration Thomas Paine was the subject
of my next book the unacknowledged
founding father but that the the crucial
thing is popular sovereignty and the for
the first time the idea that rights are
innate in humans not in monarchs not in
bishops and not derived from the heavens
though a creator is mentioned it's not
specified that they are common property
any human can claim and this is this
idea which I believe is still the most
revolutionary idea was at that time
extraordinarily so when mr. Jefferson
finally becomes president the very first
thing he does is to declare war and he
does it without consulting Congress
and he sends the American fleet with the
Marine Corps way out too far from land
and in too far gone in time for when for
them to be recalled when he finally does
tell Congress he sent them this is
because he wanted to make absolutely
sure that this war was a success the war
he declared was known to us as the
Barbary war and be largely forgotten I
think now in our history but of extreme
importance not just as America's first
war but as a war of liberation the war
was against what as I say Varley called
the Barbary States these are more
properly described as the states of the
Ottoman Empire in North Africa what we
would now call Algeria Morocco Tripoli
excuse me Tunisia and Libya Tripoli
would have been lived in Tripoli that
then would be Libya now in other words
they were the Ottoman States they
commanded the entrance to the
Mediterranean from the Atlantic the
Straits of Gibraltar The Pillars of
Hercules they were in an extraordinary
position to impose their will on
navigation and it's calculated now by
the best historians this is a lot of
this is quite recent work that between
1750 say about 1750 and about 1820 about
a million and a half Europeans and
Americans were kidnapped by these past
taken from their ships the ships were
taken - and pressed into slavery you
could you could avoid this if you paid a
tribute to the relevant potentate the
bay or salt on which most European
powers tended to do there was if there
was a tariff for it but the United
States was in a weak position at that
point to be paying the tribute and the
British crown which had up until then
been guaranteeing American shipping was
rather vindictive and probably in fact
made bargains with the Barbary States in
order that they would particularly pick
upon American shipping showing them what
they'd lost by losing the protection of
the Union Jack so the situation was
pretty
desperate these ships were you know very
powerful to they it's recorded that
almost the entire I'm not making this as
a local pitch because I'm in Annapolis
but the entire town of Baltimore in
Ireland was carried off entire
population in one night by Arab slavers
and never seen again they arranged that
far north and all the way down into the
Atlantic Jefferson had tried very hard
to negotiate with the Barbary ambassador
mr. Abdul Rahman he went to London to
see him and said by what right do you do
this to American shipping we did not
take part in the Crusades we did not
take part in the reconquest of Andalusia
we are not a Christian country there is
a treaty there still extant still is the
law of the land in this country the
Treaty of Tripoli which among other
things states and has the full support
of Congress and the Senate in stating
the United States is in no description a
Christian country worth remembering by
the way when you hear some of today's
blowhards but Abdulrahman replied that
this was irrelevant that that any
non-muslim could be taken into slavery
according to the to the Koran and all
non-muslims and other infidels were to
be punished and if they didn't want to
pay the special tax they could they
could expect to be treated as chattel
well it was decided not to be spoken to
in this tone of voice and the fleet set
sail and after a fairly prolonged
bombardment I won't tell you the whole
story and some very heroic operations
now associated with the names of Stephen
Decatur in particular a change of policy
was imposed they the the the practice
was given up of piracy and enslavement
and the it's the reason why the first
line of the marine anthem from the halls
of Montezuma to the shores of Tripoli is
the line that it is because that's the
first time we the American flag was
planted in war on another country's soil
this was a very brisk start to mr.
Jefferson's presidential life and he
meant it
I think to why no I argued strongly in
my book to show that the American
Revolution was not for Americans alone
that the ideas that it embodied were he
hopes
capable of universal emulation he had
they would spread he believed they had
spread to France he'd been disappointed
by the defeat of his friend the Marquis
de Lafayette in the fracture side within
the French Revolution but nonetheless he
believed that slowly and by degrees the
American Revolution would export itself
and could be exported by violence if
necessary or if negated and I mention it
because among other things we can say
that at least partially it cancels the
shame of the exclusion of the
anti-slavery clause from the declaration
of 1776 at least mr. Jefferson in his
lifetime did put down one slave trade
but I'm coming back to that subject too
it's one revolution none for now
sketchily admit the Enlightenment
nation-building in order for the United
States to be a revolution that could be
emulated and exported and fought for
overseas it had to be a serious
continental power as a Jefferson's main
preoccupation throughout his life he had
various principles sometimes Federalists
sometimes anti-federalists sometimes
Republicans sometimes democratic any of
these principles he would sacrifice if
it gained territory or trade or power or
influence for United States when this
country began we were gathered today in
Annapolis which was briefly its capital
would still be in it if it remained the
way it was but the way it was was to
this continent the northern American
continent what Chile is to the other
side of the South American continent a
long ribbon-like country trapped between
the ocean and the mountains chill a very
charming 13 colonies very charming too
but you see how easily they might again
have fallen prey to any renewal of
violence between Britain Spain and
France it was a very tenuous existence
for Jefferson the absolutely critical
thing was to gain control of the
Mississippi thought we can do that we
can become a real continental power the
term United States of America originally
coined I think this is disputed but I
think it's true by Thomas Paine weighed
with him very much he thought there
should be more States and he was always
looking for expansion first in the
northwest but above all towards the
Mississippi and
the chance came in the early part of the
last century when despite the fact that
he had always been in favor of the
French Revolution and even its burnup
artists an expression against the
British Empire he was never really
neutral as between Britain and France I
had gotten to taking immense political
risks to be identified with the
pro-french faction he wrote to the
French government and said we want you
to sell us New Orleans we must have it
and Mississippi at all costs we
understand you're willing to sell the
game the idea had been given him by
Thomas Paine said I think they're so
broke now said pain that they would they
would sell us Louisiana Jefferson said
if you don't do it if you don't accept
our offer in order to gain control of
the Mississippi I'm willing to make a
naval and military alliance with Great
Britain something that would have been
unthinkable for him to say under any
other circumstances and mr. Italian
wrong Napoleon's chief politician had to
admit that they were so broke and so
much and how either that he would give
them more than they'd asked for every
French territory in North America he
wasn't even quite sure of the full
extent of it they could have the lot for
a given price which comes down to if you
take Henry Adams this beautiful
formulation doubling the size of the
United States in one day at the cost of
10 cents an acre the most extraordinary
and deal in history almost makes you
believe in manifest destiny and well
especially when you think just a
digression but only a few years later
mr. Lincoln's Secretary of State Macias
mr. Seward is talking to his Russian
counterpart who says we've got this
boring extension of Siberia on your side
of the Straits called Alaska it's no use
to man or beast you know do fancy buying
leasing okay I'll see what I've got on
me
oh-ho maybe God is on the side of the
United States after all anyway for
Jefferson this was the absolutely
critical thing and this is the bit that
I like and I make it I make it a crux
point in my in my book I don't believe
in numinous dates or anything like that
even though mr. Jefferson and I actually
have the same birthday
but the birthday of the United States
fourth of July is also the date on which
Louisiana Purchase is announced in The
Gazette in Washington and happier still
later in the afternoon of that day Lewis
and Clark received their instructions to
depart from Pittsburgh and go west and
to Jefferson was able to tell them he's
already told them you will have to meet
with and treat with many Indian nations
and their leaders he urges on them
always to treat them with the greatest
of respect ask them to enter into
negotiations with Washington but he's
able to tell them Lewis and Clark what
they can now tell these Indian leaders
which is gentlemen you already live in
the United States imagine the reign of
the Emperor of France is over and will
never come back the Spanish are not
coming back you are Americans already
and so would on that 4th of July he's
able to sent send off the greatest
enlightenment expedition ever founded
there's there's a word for Orientalism
for the way that Napoleon but around the
same time sent all kinds of artists and
scientists and geographers and
seismologists and botanists and
anthropologists to Egypt that we call
that Orientalism Occidental ISM is what
mr. Jefferson was practicing he made
sure that Lewis and Clark went to
Philadelphia from the great city of the
Enlightenment for a long course in
astronomy how to guide themselves by the
Stars stellar navigation in the curing
of cholera the treatment of car excuse
me not a quarter of smallpox I beg your
pardon that not irrelevant digression
here
Jefferson vaccinated everyone on his
estate at Monticello including the
people who where's property against
smallpox
he was a great partisan of dr. Jenner's
invention he even discovered a method by
which it could be kept cool
and not lose its force when it was being
transported there was a problem with it
losing its potency he discovered that by
keeping a cold with water or ice it
could it could be taken quite a long
distance
he taught arranged for Lewis and Clark
to be taught how to administer smallpox
injections to Indians which is a small
compensation for the terrible damage
done to their culture by the small pox
that was brought to the new world by the
colonists Timothy Dwight famous devine
of the time well known as the founder of
Yale still took the view that
vaccination against smallpox was an
interference with God's design shouldn't
be practiced I suppose he would have to
be right since it would have to have
been God who designed smallpox in the
first place this is the trap you dig for
yourself as a creationist so in all
these other ways these merciful I became
very very highly educated people trained
in all these matters and navigation
agriculture they would take given seeds
and plants to take with them they were
given instructions on how to keep
cuttings and bring back specimens of
botany on their return it was a
genuinely scientific expedition and of
course by the time it was over
it could be safely said that the United
States would one day extend as far as
California and Oregon which of course it
eventually did though mr. Lincoln's
greatest ambition was to go to
California and even he as president
never managed to do it nor of course did
mr. Jefferson but by the time the
Jefferson presidency is over we know
that there's going to be a major country
called the United States of America and
everyone else in the world knows this
country cannot be messed around with
militarily and it has a revolutionary
manifesto somewhere about its person in
the form of a declaration and now a
constitution so the whole wheel of
history eventually turns enormous lee in
the Jefferson years so I left slavery to
the last because I because I had to but
because also it touches all the other
things I've mentioned it's a consistent
thread throughout the whole thing
Jefferson tried when he was a young
member of the Virginia House of
Burgesses
under British rule to have at least the
right for the right of manumission as it
was called the right of a slave owner
has to say to liberate another slave
that was not a thing you were allowed to
do in polite society it was it wasn't
you weren't able to set that that
example we fought for that he fought
during the Declaration as you know to
have a clause included that would ban
not just the trade but the the trade in
slaves but also the holding of slaves
and it didn't get that written in wasn't
at the Constitutional Convention did
succeed in having slavery prevented in
the Northwest Territories and that
ordinance will try his best to do so
past the past the relevant legislation
in his notes on the state of Virginia
which I strongly recommend that you read
rights such good abolitionist prose that
you don't really need after you've read
that to read even Frederick Douglas of
Maryland all the arguments against
slavery are in there already
not just the degrading effect that it
has upon the slaves themselves which is
so to speak taken for granted but the
the extremely degrading and dehumanizing
effect that it has on those who profit
from it and who hold other people as
property it's probably not being put any
better or more tersely and we can add
with pride
that's the slave trade of the Barbary
States is put down by American force
good but when the United States is
doubled in size by the Louisiana
Purchase and when a whole new world and
another chance for another whole new
start is presented Thomas Payne and Joel
Barlow two of his closest friends go to
the president say look mr. president we
can start again do not have any slavery
in the New Territories
don't bring any slaves into Louisiana
don't unload anyone at New Orleans
that's got has to stop go and get some
good thrifty German immigrants and
settlers and get them settled on the
land and allow freed slaves from other
states to come and be given land grants
in Louisiana we can start again
and Jefferson said no because he was
afraid of what had happened in Haiti he
was afraid of the Haitian Revolution
shop again negates his general support
for revolutionary activity if it wasn't
for the Haitian Revolution there
wouldn't be the United States because if
it wasn't for the Haitian Revolution to
which we are in an unacknowledged debt
it wasn't for the heroic slave rebellion
of Toussaint L'Ouverture Napoleon
wouldn't have lost his army in the West
Indies wouldn't have gone bankrupt
wouldn't have needed a self
louisia never forget this but Jefferson
didn't like the idea of a black
rebellion he didn't want to see that
spreading to the Carolinas that's the
first thing second the crucial thing for
Louisiana was the sugar crop and the
sugar crop I'm getting near to half an
hour I should stop in a second we will
yes but I mean you've got to be
spellbinding for two or 45 minutes and
if and if you're spellbinding you don't
need 45s sir but thank you all the same
I'm glad to see no one's yet stirred or
that it's I don't mind them looking at
their words I hate it when they start
shaking so two points here on technique
you see the Enlightenment the discovery
of wonderful new techniques isn't always
progressive it isn't always revolution
it isn't always emancipating mr. Eli
Whitney's cotton gin is a wonderful
discovery it really is but unfortunately
it makes cotton a lot more profitable
and cotton is never going to stop being
labor-intensive so there's a wonderful
new invention that actually doesn't
emancipate people it rather continues to
hold them in slavery well the cotton
interest had dominated that far but now
the sugar interest takes over and if the
sugar harvest isn't cut and brought in
quickly then the Caribbean islands
thought outside the American orbit
they'll dominate the trade instead so
Jefferson decides to capitulate and the
chance of a second new start is is lost
consciously lost because he had the
advice and the police of pain and bother
not to do it and because of the enormous
size of the Louisiana Purchase it means
it's going to be carving and cloning
into new states all the time it's
already begun to do so and it means that
by the end of this process in other
words the vast addition of territory and
the huge extension of slavery that very
very soon
that pretty nearly by the time of
Jefferson's death it would be the case
that the number of slave states or the
number of free states would be
approximately equal state of affairs
which is later occurred in a very
momentous speech by Abraham Lincoln who
says that he doesn't think the Union can
long endure half slave and half free
well that admire of Jefferson has to
concede that this was the state of
affairs gifted to mr. Lincoln passed on
to him by mr. Jefferson and this is a
terrible irony for those of us who
believe in the in the American ideal
well I think that it's now that the the
bawdy hand of time is on the prick of
noon as I believe Mercutio says some of
will correct me if I'm wrong and I think
I have sketched for you why Jefferson is
so fascinating why so paradoxical and
why as I close my book in saying I
believe that he illustrates that history
is not a morality tale but a tragedy
it's been nice having you as my
prisoners and I'm now happy to be your
hostage Legendre thank you for coming
have questions
you have questions ladies and gentlemen
please go to the microphone in the
middle of the room to ask them thank you
for your talk so it's on alpha Hut okay
thank you sir I recently heard that the
declaration the first line Jefferson
have written we hold these truths to be
sacred in an altar bowl and then
Franklin revised it to say we hold these
truths to be self-evident so I'm
wondering I mean Jefferson's original
formulation doesn't sound as
enlightenment as Franklin's and I'm
wondering if you had any thoughts about
that I mean I mean words are kind of
symbolic of our underlying experiences
so it does I think it's a distinction
with a difference
we had had sacred and an Oregon says
self-evident Thanks you're quite right
though sacred doesn't necessarily have
to have a non secular meaning you're
certainly right to the best of my
knowledge I think it's in affiliates in
Jerry Weinberger's excellent new book on
Benjamin Franklin but anyway that the
term self-evident is his I mean remember
this is quite an impressive drafting
committee they've got that they have
they have Franklin and Jefferson and
several other gifted people they also
have the collected works of John Locke
which if you look at and then compare
with the final document is an
extraordinarily def bit of plagiarism in
the word for word almost is the bit for
example which says that people are
likely oft often will put up with a
tremendous amount of oppression and
inconvenience if they see no other way
of living that you can load them with
more and more taxes and chains and
sinful but when a long train of abuses
usurpations and so forth culminates then
they'll rebel and now that's more most
word-for-word from Lords treatise on
civil government if Franklin had been
the chief drafter instead of just one of
the committee the might even have been a
joke
in the Declaration but with Jefferson
you could be absolutely sure there would
not be with the one of the sad things
about writing about him mr. discovered
it really had no sense of humor at all
and the proof of this is he thought
tristram shandy was a hilarious book and
would read it aloud to his wife and have
him/her Martha
Sally's half-sister read it to him on
the long winter evenings you just have
to picture that for a laugh fest I
greatly enjoyed your exposing the
various issues that your book has and
the little details that you've given us
and aside from your birthday July 4th
what was the primary interest or
stimulus for you to tackle or study and
then write about Jefferson um Jefferson
isn't born on the fourth of July neither
am i so I may have run those two things
together in fact though I was born April
13th and so was he he was actually born
on April the twenty-something he was
born on to the old calendar I wasn't
wondered what the astrologers did the
horoscope artists did whenever one had
to shift over a Zodiac or two but your
Jefferson would have stayed in Aries I
think by his David on his tombstone it
gives both dates why wasn't i interested
in him well I would never have dared
propose writing a book about him I don't
think when I was approached and asked to
do so I thought yes almost immediately
because everything one writes if about
America is in some way writing about
Jefferson as I say Washington is
necessary presidency to study there are
several others I'd say we're necessary
obviously Lincoln certainly Roosevelt
these are quite short intervals of time
Jefferson's right there from the
beginning the declaration prior to that
the preparation for the revolution the
Committees of Correspondence the final
appeal to King George the vindication of
the rights of North Americans
then Paris where he helps to draft the
Declaration of the Rights of Man first
time ever such doctor have been made in
French soil becomes Universal
Declaration then Secretary of State then
vice-president then for the a lien and
Sedition Act contest all of this then
the war with the Barbary States then the
attempt to use international sanctions
for the first time ever as a means of
preventing war is the reason why second
term is such a disappointment because he
thinks that the economic warfare
argument that the boycott will embargo
will bring an end to the war which in
Britain in France and the constant raids
on American shipping and I actually do
think if it had been given a bit more
time it might have worked it's the first
time anyone's tried that as a let alone
as a superpower and then in retirement
writing more papers than most people
could elite could read in a lifetime
designing a wonderful library helping
out the Library of Congress after the
burning of 1812 the University of
Virginia and the Jefferson Bible which I
also recommend everyone should get hold
of a copy of you can usually I think the
Unitarian Church has published a good
addition addition both Forest Church
Jefferson took the Bible in one hand in
a pair of scissors no razor blade in the
other and cut out all the bits that were
mad or immoral or mythical or self
contradictory or other were otherwise
wicked or absurd leaving him with as you
can imagine extremely short book but but
quite terse and this this was his
contribution to enlightenment think he
didn't dare publish in his lifetime but
it was one of his that was just one of
his retirement jobs and he could do it
in all relevant languages whether it's a
parallel text so that's why I wanted to
derive much
thank you very much it's been
enlightening I'm wondering for another
reason for your writing this might have
something to do with past being prologue
for the future I heard you say that that
Jefferson was in favor of of exporting
democracy through violence
starting a pre-emptive war overseas
without consulting Congress his attitude
towards religion these strike me as
vaguely familiar concepts today I'm
wondering what what you think
Jefferson's attitude might be towards
the current political frame of mind
thank you well I'm glad I didn't trail
that code in vain
first well the thing about it is as you
know this past is prologue stuff is all
very well but it's very very difficult
to ask what anyone would do much beyond
their own lifetime I mean if we cuz I
read a book about George Orwell once I
said I he died in 1951 but I said from
what he what he wrote in about from the
tropics he'd written on I disagreed with
Mary McCarthy and others who for what he
would have supported the Vietnam War
he's still being alive and I thought I
could prove it because of what he'd
written about Indochina and because of
what his attitude to Empire as well as
to communism was I thought I had a
reasonable shot of saying that that's
only extending matters by a couple of
decades really what he would have
thought much beyond 1984 as it were
which is pretty important well with
Jefferson therefore it's not very much
harder if he was to come back the things
that would astonish him would be most of
all I think what we call mixed I think
it's a silly term marriage in other
words he would be amazed to see how many
descendants he and Sammy had and where
they were living with whom and how many
of them had been living on the white
side of the color line since at least
the sense of servation 20 all his
children by Sally Ann Chi were
registered as white in that in that head
for example the extent of that would
amaze with the pleasant attitude
American womanhood there's something
amazing about his indifference on this
point he never says anything about the
rights of women doesn't seem to
interests him at all he thought they
were great and he thought they were
doing perfectly well exactly where they
were that he would be astounded by
American girls shall we say the girls
these days and he would be appalled that
we had not yet conquered Canada that's
that would have really not you you mean
to say that the British flag still flies
over North you know I mean see we have
have the young men of America being
asleep whereas their honor whereas their
fire disgraceful state of affair what he
would have said about our current
difficulty i rage I know I mean
therefore he certainly he had had a
warning from ambassador Abner Ehrman of
Tripoli in the meeting they had with
John Adams in London of the menace of
radical Islam he'd been told in terms
know the Koran gives us the right to
make you slaves or to kill you and we
claim it as a religious right that on
behalf of our kings I mean the
combination of the two would have been
very powerfully nauseating to him
obviously and so it's yes one can
extrapolate to that I think used the
term pre-emptive war will you see as
with Iraq since they've been fighting
going on all this time anyway never
stopped it wasn't even really a
ceasefire in 1991 it's the word
pre-emptive may be the wrong one I mean
if a million and a half Europeans and
Americans have been enslaved by this
country it's been going on as a regular
business stopping it by surprise naval
attack isn't really pre-emptive in fact
you should be impeached if you don't do
it you have to be able to know who your
country's enemies are and deal with them
by force and with Brio and that's what
he did but I know that that spirit is
not the current one
you didn't have any stomach for that and
many people in fact rather as the Greeks
used to call they were so frightened of
the Furies that they wouldn't name them
they wouldn't say the Furies they'd say
the humanities the kindly ones call them
that they might make nice
all units under the breath it's like
Voldemort people now say people call mr.
sack are we with his plan for an
ultimate caliphate based on the official
assim position of Taliban law and with
the intention of annexing and overcoming
all of its neighbors and who uses the
methods of beheading and torture as
sectarian warfare and sabotage of
schools and hospitals and and even
mosques in pursuit people call him an
insurgent I'll try to make nice with
someone with whom that's pointless so
there they're trying to hope that we
don't have to fight these people because
they're scared of them well this is
contemptible I don't think I need to
Jefferson's authority to say that well
maybe she wants to do it for sitting
down I don't mind we go up story
I'm afraid the our friends from c-span
need you too sorry about that just very
briefly could you elaborate on your
knowledge of his poetry writing when he
started and over his lifetime I don't
know anything I don't know any Jefferson
poetry
I mean I'd know that he had a great
company had a great command office he'd
be able to quote a lot of it from from
Latin and Greek as well but if he wrote
any I feel lamentable ignorant of the
fact he doesn't seem to me to be in the
poetic type I have to say
there is a sort of there is a ghastly
little sort of sampler verse very near
the end of his life
I think it's inversely made if it's sort
of basically thing about about his dead
children being angels or I can't even
bear to think about it actually it's so
it's written to try and cheer up his
younger daughter about about her dead
sisters it's the product of a weak
moment sorry I can't be any more I just
curious about what happened to those
million-and-a-half people that ended up
in North Africa did they blend in with
the population are they some of them
still enslaved so we don't know the
blacks here in this country what
happened to the whites that ended up
there whether a number of memoirs of
them because some escaped and unlike
those Africans who are unlucky enough to
be taken into the Middle Passage and
then to America dying in huge numbers on
the way and never seeing Africa again
these people could be ransomed in a huge
amount of activity in a town like this
at about that time there would have been
at every Sunday service a short talk
about what was happening and a request
for money to try and redeem or ransom
people because it was partly a racket it
was partly a protection racket as well
you could you could pay not to be
enslaved and if you were you could pay
to be ransomed but so some of them were
ransomed and we have extraordinary
memoirs of them my the top of my head I
should be able to recommend at least one
book there's a book called captives by a
very good English historian called Linda
Colley who's greatly enhanced our
knowledge of this period I think that
that's gives the best account many of
them were put to work in the desert and
elsewhere and were died as slaves I mean
we'll work to death many died in jail
where they were held as possible objects
of bargaining
and ransom they're kept in a cellar till
someone would raise the money for them
often they died for the maltreatment
they're some of them the young ones were
sold into prot into prostitution that
into child brothels in the in the ports
along the North Africa coast and that's
the story it's it's rather I'm afraid as
you would expect that the there are I've
noticed quite a lot of very
light-skinned people especially in
Morocco and it's conceivable that
there's a certain amount of that because
the would it be no no prohibition of any
kind or an intermarriage well not that
there really was in in America either in
that there was no police no prohibition
on inter I hate to say I won't use the
word racial because I don't believe that
our species is subdivided into race but
you know what I mean black white sex was
not illegal in any way at least not in
one direction if you follow me don't
have to draw your picture there may have
been some of that too and with many we
just don't know they vanished they
vanished
they vanished from history too until
recently slave today is that so no the
wrists still slavery in in North Africa
as before it's almost always a licensed
by the Koran the some in Chad there's a
good deal in Sudan of course I don't
think it's I'm sure it's not still legal
in Morocco or Algeria or Libya or
Tunisia
no but in the this sort of Saharan belt
there is there is a more than just
people trafficking there's actual
indentured slavery yes and those people
would be the descendants of the same
prophet ears well we know the names of
the people who became rich in West
Africa by selling their kinsmen we know
we know what the family fortunes are in
West Africa in a lot of cases in
particular cases of case of Benin for
example so that if the reparations
argument which some people want to
reopen which I consider a very
interesting argument is ever reopen
there's a question of who should be paid
will be of course very hard but possible
to decipher who should pay would be
interesting too
and we would know in some cases which
African potentates and which great
fortunes should be made to to cough up
some conscience money so I say bring it
on because it's it's very educational
in the unless I'm mistaken most people
in this room don't know this already
my general experience is people dead
well it's true
so it's worth knowing and I think it
would it would instruct our children in
in what the past of all this was so
here's to hear your your views on the
thing that was probably the most popular
thing that Jefferson did in his lifetime
and enriched in retrospect still doesn't
seem like a terrible great idea and that
was his embargoes well I did mention
debuggers a bit saying it was the first
time that anyone tried to use economic
diplomacy instead of warfare as a
composition of a dispute the the problem
with the war the problem with it really
is the United States has a coastline and
a border that's far too long at least
did then including with the awful factor
of Canada
Jefferson resented so much but if you're
if you're in say upstate Vermont and you
someone comes around from the excise man
it's the office and said you can't trade
this way anymore because the president
wants to get a peace agreement between
Britain and France in the United States
they're going to say well I'm just
waiting till you leave you know it's not
popular at all
he Jefferson thought that okay that will
happen of course some people will resent
it which they really really really did
especially along this coast
the Maryland coast but he thought no
never mind it will have a long-run
effect people will start going for what
we would now call import substitution
they'll instead of importing things that
start to try and manufacture them for
themselves and there was in fact quite a
lot of import substitution done and
people did begin to to invest in the
idea of making it in America instead of
importing it an argument still goes on
of course but in the end the Congress
has lost patience it was too unpopular
and we'll we'll never know if it would
have
the French the Bonaparte's side was
weakening at that point considerably
Paine and Jefferson also discussed
setting up something like the United
Nations an international Confederation
to put down things like piracy but also
to avoid war two mutually reduce the
size of navies to avoid wasteful
competition and to try and open up
Spanish America by getting Spain to
loosen its hold on the Southern Cone but
that didn't come to any come to anything
in their lifetimes either
please what do you think Jefferson would
think about the Iraq adventure that were
in now
well would you would let me see I'll
have to submit myself to the safekeeping
of others in the audience would you
ladies and gentlemen not say it already
I had already answered that question I'm
relieved sir pay attention in the back
but what's the thing surprise you in
doing a research writing this book about
Jefferson any surprises yes I thought
I'd knew about the Sally Hemings
relationship as Morris everybody now
does there's a small group that holds
out that says that the DNA evidence
isn't completely conclusive because it
could have been another male Jefferson
at a rather same time around the same
place that's I may not even be
technically true but if it if it is I
don't think that it can possibly cancel
the argument that my friend Annette
gordon-reed made in her brilliant book
just strongly recommend it's just called
Thomas Jefferson and Sally Hemings an
American story is the subtitle before
she did all this work before the DNA
test was run and when you know that
Sally was not as his property but his
wife's half-sister
in other words Sarah Hemings and Martha
Jefferson had the same father and
grandfather both of them English why
should any race
Anglo that she was a privileged house
servant who was in the room when Martha
died and heard Jefferson say to his wife
promised he'd never marry again that
she's taken that they meet on French
soil where slavery is illegal and though
he doesn't need any extra staff at the
American Embassy he asks her she'd like
to stay in perhaps join his town and
then his letters show expenses for
for her and for a separate place for her
to live so I think I need to draw you
one of those pictures I keep mentioning
the critical thing to know I think and
that a net discovers so brilliantly is
when Jefferson's little daughter died he
he couldn't stand it um it had it been
so much death that he was he said you
must have the remaining one brought him
in Paris where the older one already was
he must send her over I can't bear any
more of this I want to have them with me
and he sends this to his cousin's the
Epps's who
and he says you might send old misses
and he mentioned some old slave woman
who's a stout respectable person to
bring the child across but while the
letter is in transit he doesn't know
that this will this not older older
woman has become pregnant again she
can't make the trip so here he doesn't
without consulting his cousin say well
the only girl we can think of on the
strength the only slave we've got who
could do it who's smart and bright and
so on and reliable this Sally will give
her the other child Sally and they'll
cross together
Jefferson meets them not knowing who is
going to be escorting his daughter and
the plan had been for the other slave
woman to go home on the next boat having
delivered little kid he doesn't let
Sally Hemings go home he asks her to
stay and though I defend him to the last
ditch as a secularist I here's what I
think I think that when he saw Sally
getting off that boat he thought oh
maybe there is a God after all that's
what I think he said
it couldn't really be any plainer well
you know so none of this really is you
asked for a surprise okay so I thought I
felt I knew all that but what I realized
as I went through it and with the help
of our net Gordon Reed and her
extraordinary scholarship on this is
that we're accustomed to argue it like
this would Jefferson have done this
could he have done it so all that partly
with the rather awful implication that I
wouldn't have lowered himself with
either a black person or a slave
depending on what attitude to Jefferson
you take it would have been as it were
beneath him Garry wills historian I
normally admire and have learned a lot
from makes the outrageous suggestion
that Sally Hemings was a prostitute
that she would sleep with anyone on the
estate for money for which there's no
evidence at all there's nothing to
support such an opprobrious charge but
what if as a net proposes what if Sally
Hemings had a say in this
what if she thought well here I am in
Paris he's asked me to stay slavery
isn't illegal here my brother's here
working as a cook being taught to do
French dishes it's a lot nicer than a
mountaintop in Albemarle County
Virginian the guy's obviously under
pressure he's a widower and but he's you
know still as it were he's still a the
man I could do worse it's an upgrade and
what she may well have said to him is
okay but if I have any children and
they're not going to be slaves mr.
Jefferson
sir because that seems to be what the
bargain was because all her children
were freed his children by her were
freed and no other said well and so was
she and in law you can you may not say
that acting as if you've made a bargain
proves that you made one but you can
adduce it as evidence that a bargain was
made and if you look at it like that and
if you imagine her as a partner in it
which i think it's only fair to do since
she was obviously a very smart and tough
and brave girl then you think well and
this is what I proposed in my book well
why not consider her not as a buried
scandal or was an object of
we'll discuss but is one of America's
founding mothers now buried under the
under the Hampton Inn I think it is good
courtyard Ramada Inn courtyard in
Charlottesville under its parking lot
but that maybe we could do something
about that and the just Clinton closing
loosely and Truscott the third was a
direct descendant through the Coolidge
family of Thomas Jefferson a senior
member of the Jefferson Family
Association meets every at Monticello he
refuses now to go to any more of the
family reunion events because they won't
allow Sally's children to be buried in
the family graveyard on the mountainside
they still won't but he has produced
with a net self a book wonderful work of
photographs of all of the descendants
all right across the country several
dozen of them we can trace and that's
the perfect refutation that book of
Jefferson's belief that the slaves
should be freed they'd have to depart
from the United States once they are
free they couldn't stay on once they
couldn't be free black people living in
in the United States it's that it's the
perfect refutation in practice of the
pessimism that poisoned his and his life
and that's such a blot on his record
sorry for long answer but a lot of that
was new to me as I hope and believe it
may be to you and I thought it was worth
worth the speculation mr. Hitchens thank
you so much for your insights ah speed a
pleasure thank you
thank you
yeah that was just insurance you're less
about the bigger up Jim Burnie should
get your hammer you want to go into I
have to tell you I found you know I was
Christopher Hitchens the first of five
authors will bring you today from the
Annapolis Book Festival starting